herr pofalla wir sind jetzt gerade an
einem punkt wo es noch wenig
hochrechnungen gibt
der abend ist noch lang trotzdem sieht
es im moment so aus als hätte die afg
ein - hier stehen das ist nicht das mit
dem sieg gerechnet haben richtig wir
sind mit dem ergebnis sehr zufrieden wir
haben ungefähr 23 5 prozent was die
aktuellen hochrechnungen angeht
das haben wir ja damit haben wir unser
ergebnis gehalten also wir sind sehr
zufrieden ich bin stolz auf unsere
parteien möchte mich da auch bedanken
bei unseren vielen wahlkämpfe sie waren
hier aber angetreten um stärkste kraft
zu werden
das sind sie nicht geworden wir waren
angetreten um über 20 prozent zu
bekommen wir haben unsere wie gesagt
unser wähleranteil gehalten
das wurde natürlich medial hochgespielt
dass wir hier noch stärkste kraft werden
wollen das ist für uns natürlich auch
motivation aber politik ist ein marathon
das nächste mal wenn wir vor der cdu
sein sie sind spitzenkandidat für die
bundestagswahl parteivorsitzender
ich frag mal so was können sie denn
eigentlich im bund von der af den
sachsen anhalt lernen denn das sind ja
im bund ergebnisse die sie eigentlich
erreichen
nun gut wir haben ja gesehen gerade in
ostdeutschland sind wir volkspartei es
gibt in sachsen anhalt nur noch zwei
volksparteien ist die cdu und die afd
das wollen wir natürlich auf bundesebene
leisten und das ist natürlich auch die
motivation für den wahlkampf wird ein
streik wahlkampf gemacht hier macht man
straßenwahlkampf und ich denke das
brauchen wir auch in den anderen
bundesländern auch in den alten
bundesländern und das ist für mich die
motivation die ich mitnehme und auch die
unsere mitglieder mitnehmen
deswegen war dieses ergebnis vor der
bundestagswahl für uns auch so wichtig
sie haben hier in sachsen anhalt einen
landesverband der extremist ja meine
fraktion die geschlossen dem ehemaligen
dem jetzt aufgelösten flügel angehört
die politiker hier von der afg sind mit
schrillen tönen sag ich mal aufgetreten
bin ich jetzt noch mal die frage stellen
was kann die afg sozusagen auf
bundesebene von sachsen an erklären
heißt das sie müssen radikaler werden um
bessere ergebnisse zu fahren nein wir
haben hier klar gezeigt dass wir als
opposition auftreten und das will ja die
bürger auch sehen dass wir als
oppositionspartei auch wahrnehmbar sind
dass wir andere themen und auch inhalte
haben wie die anderen parteien und das
hat uns ja hier zumindest in sachsen
anhalt sehr gut getan wenn man sieht wie
die puppe die ergebnisse der linken der
grünen aber auch der fdp ist haben wir
hier klar davon profitiert wir haben ja
auch die ersten wahlanalysen gesehen wir
haben
den arbeitern zugelegt mit den unseren
sozialen themen aus der mittelschicht
heraus das nehmen wir aus dieser wahl
auch mit und das ist auch ansporn für
uns für die bundestagswahl
was hat denn der wähler konkret hier in
sachsen anhalt davon wenn er als die
welt dann ist es ja so dass sie nicht
mehr antreten um regierungsverantwortung
zu übernehmen woran märkte eigentlich
der wähler der ihnen ja die stimme hier
geschenkt hat dass die afd irgendwas für
ihn verändert hat nun wenn wir uns den
wählerwillen mal anschauen und auf denen
sollte man ja vielleicht mal sich auch
konzentrieren dann ist doch ganz klar
was der wähler ihr möchte der wähler
möchte hier cdu auf der regierung wenn
man das ergebnis zusammen gekommen um
über 50% bürgerlich-konservativ das muss
man einfach auch mal respektieren und
die cdu muss erklären wir werden sind
gesprächsbereit warum sie mit uns nicht
der regieren möchte und muss dem wähler
erklären warum mit uns keine
regierungsarbeit möglich ist also ich
sehe das wesentlich positiver als sie
würden ihnen widersprechen denn um punkt
an dem logisch ist dass die erste kraft
und die zweite kraft automatisch
bedeutet dass die wähler möchten dass
diese beiden parteien zusammen gehen
aber das mal jenseits davon
meine frage zieht eigentlich darauf ab
sie haben in den letzten fünf jahren
hier in der opposition gesessen
selbstverständlich die bürger die ihnen
ja die stimme geben die ihnen eben auch
ihr vertrauen schenken die sorgen haben
natürlich in sachsen anhalt für sie für
die haben sie ja nichts verbessert hier
in sachsen anhalt wird das würde ich so
nicht sehen wir sind als korrektiv als
opposition gewehr wir machen
wahrnehmbare oppositionsarbeit wehr
setzen untersuchungsausschuss auch in
sachsen anhalt ein um aufklärung zu
bringen wir treiben die regierung vor
uns her das ist auch die aufgabe eine
opposition und es ist wichtig das ist
eine opposition wie die afg gibt wie
sind die alternative in vielen punkten
was die themen angeht und das braucht
auch eine regierung die sich wie auch
immer jetzt zusammensetzen wird die cdu
wird sich wieder zwei partner suchen
müssen also nicht gerade feste
regierungsverhältnisse ist haben wir in
den letzten jahren hier auch in
sachsen-anhalt gesehen dass die diese
regierung doch sehr gewagt hat und von
daher bieten wir immer
gesprächsbereitschaft dialog an um vor
allen dingen gute politik für die bürger
in sachsen anhalt zu machen kommen wir
noch mal auf die afg im ganzen sie haben
in baden württemberg
ein schlechteres ergebnis eingefahren
sie haben in rheinland pfalz ein
schlechteres ergebnis eingefahren hier
jetzt sagen sie sagen sie haben sich
gehalten vielleicht steht am ende ein
kleines minus kleines plus das werden
wir noch sehen im laufe des abends ist
der peak erreicht
oder sieht man an diesen wahlergebnissen
auch eine zerrissene partei
nein wir sind also ich sag mal wäre ich
bin wie gesagt sehr positiv mit diesem
ergebnis und das ist regionale lokale
unterschiede in den parteien gibt es da
ganz normal wenn man sieht dass die spd
sich zum beispiel auch hier in sachsen
anhalt mittlerweile fast verabschiedet
dass wir mit den sozialen themen doch
hier wesentlich mehr punkten bin ich da
optimistisch dass wir das auch in den
alten bundesländern tun werden gerade
wenn wir uns die die themen angucken
hören der die korona maßnahme zu ende
denkt wenn wir die wirtschaftlichen
folgen sehen werden auch die sozialen
themen in den westlichen bundesländern
von bedeutung zu an bedeutung zunehmen
und dort werden wir auch in zukunft
punkten in europa ganz herzlichen dank
der bundesvorsitzende der afd